.
Hier hat sie gelebt:
in einer ländlichen Gemeinde.
Nicht weit entfernt vom Genfer See.
Ein ruhiges Leben,
eine liebevolle Familie,
ein Leben ohne grössere Ereignisse.
* Melancholische Klavierakkorde *
Adeline wurde 34 Jahre alt.
Jetzt ist sie nicht mehr da - und
doch so präsent in den Herzen jener,
die sich am 10. September versammeln,
um ihrer zu gedenken.
(Frau) Die Emotionen
sind so stark wie am ersten Tag.
Auch nach zehn Jahren.
Man hat uns
unser Licht des Lebens genommen.
Seither leben wir in Traurigkeit.
* Melancholische Klavierakkorde *
Mit Untertiteln von SWISS TXT
* Die Musik verklingt. *
12. September 2013.
Die Sozialtherapeutin Adeline Morel
begleitet einen Häftling
auf Freigang.
Der Mann wurde wegen
zwei Vergewaltigungen verurteilt.
Sein Name: Fabrice A.
Das Ziel des Ausflugs:
eine Reittherapie.
Unterwegs
halten sie an einem Geschäft.
Fabrice A.
hat einen Hufkratzer bestellt.
Doch letztlich ist es ein Messer,
das er kauft.
Gemeinsam mit Adeline
macht sich der Häftling
wieder auf den Weg zum Reithof.
Dort jedoch kommen sie nie an.
Der Ausflug endet
am Rande eines Waldes.
In den Ermittlungsakten steht,
was dann geschah.
"Sie fuhren
zu einem verlassenen Haus."
"Als Adeline merkte,
dass etwas nicht stimmte,
griff sie nach ihrem Handy."
"Er tauchte hinter ihr auf und
hielt ihr das Messer vors Gesicht."
"Zweimal sagte sie Nein."
"Fabrice A. sagte ihr,
dass er ihr nicht wehtun,
sondern nur
aus dem Gefängnis flüchten wolle."
Später, während der Beweisaufnahme,
erklärt Fabrice A.:
Adeline wird am nächsten Tag mit
durchgeschnittener Kehle aufgefunden.
Die Schweiz steht unter Schock.
Vier Monate zuvor
hatte ein rückfälliger Krimineller
eine 19-Jährige ermordet -
und jetzt Adeline.
Einmal mehr Horror und Entsetzen.
Diesmal mit einem anderen Vornamen.
Der Fall Adeline
ist nicht nur der Fall Adeline.
Es ist der Tod einer Mutter,
einer Lebensgefährtin,
einer Tochter,
einer Schwester.
Das sage ich immer wieder,
wenn man vom Fall Adeline spricht.
Denn letztendlich
ist es viel mehr als das.
Jedes Jahr am 14. März backe ich ihr
einen Geburtstagskuchen.
Das mache ich weiter -
auch seit sie gestorben ist.
Es nützt nichts. Man muss nach vorne
schauen, koste es, was es wolle.
Zehn Jahre sind eine lange Zeit.
Wir vermissen sie seit zehn Jahren.
Aber dafür wachsen die anderen
Kinder und die Enkelkinder heran.
Das ist es, was uns
den Rhythmus der Jahre vorgibt.
Wir haben vier Enkelkinder.
Aber es ist so,
dass eines von ihnen ...
... keine Mutter mehr hat.
Adelines Partner Juan hat seine Frau
und seinen Lebensentwurf verloren.
Das war ein Bruch in meinem Leben.
Alles wurde auf den Kopf gestellt.
Ich hätte mir nie vorstellen können,
meine Tochter
ohne Mutter grosszuziehen
oder dass meine Frau unter
solchen Umständen sterben würde,
dass ich ihre Eltern ...
... les parents d'Adeline ...
Ich kann nicht mehr sprechen.
Das alles war unvorstellbar.
Ich habe mir auch nicht vorgestellt,
dass ich
meine Karriere aufgeben würde,
eine neue Welt aufbauen,
um das alles zu überleben.
Das alles habe ich mir
niemals vorstellen können.
Juan schreibt an seiner Geschichte.
Sein Buch -
die Verarbeitung des Erlebten.
Es gibt die Trauer.
Daran arbeite ich.
Aber es ist die Art und Weise,
wie sie gestorben ist.
Man hat sie gedemütigt.
Sie starb
unter unwürdigen Bedingungen,
unter den Augen von jemandem,
der es genossen hat,
ihr beim Sterben zuzusehen.
Er hat sich diese Szene immer wieder
vorgestellt und alles geplant.
Sie ist allein
einen schrecklichen Tod gestorben.
Fabrice A. wurde 2017
zu lebenslanger Freiheitsstrafe
und ordentlicher Verwahrung
verurteilt.
Es fällt mir schwer,
ihn als Menschen zu bezeichnen.
Er ist kein Mensch.
Er ist böse.
Er ist der Teufel.
Wir werden immer noch davon
heimgesucht, wie sie gestorben ist.
Sie hat
die Verkörperung des Bösen erlebt.
Das ist es, was uns verfolgt.
Fabrice A. - ein Monster?
Der Mord an Adeline hat die Debatte
über rückfällige schwere Straftäter
neu entfacht.
Wer sind diese Personen?
Ist es vorstellbar, dass sie
jemals wieder freigelassen werden?
Und v.a.: Wie ticken sie?
Das ist eine grundlegende und
schwierige Frage in der Psychiatrie,
dieser Gegensatz,
den die Engländer mad or bad nennen.
Panteleimon Giannakopoulos
hat Fabrice A. nicht begutachtet.
Aber er ist eine Autorität
in der Psychiatrie.
Insbesondere im Bereich
der psychischen Störungen
von Straftätern.
Man kommt auf diese Frage zurück,
die menschlich und verständlich ist:
Ist jemand böse oder verrückt?
Für den Menschen ist es schwierig,
sich vorzustellen,
dass jemand böse sein kann,
ohne psychisch krank zu sein.
Ist Fabrice A.
also verrückt oder böse?
In den psychiatrischen Gutachten,
die nach dem Mord an Adeline
von Fabrice A. erstellt wurden,
wird ein Mann beschrieben,
der von seinem Hass auf Frauen und
seinem Kontrollzwang beherrscht wird.
Einige Sätze des Mörders
geben Aufschluss
über seine gespaltene Persönlichkeit.
* Unheilvolle Streichmusik *
Am Tag der Tat,
als er Adeline fesselt:
Adeline
w a r  unter seiner Kontrolle.
Warum also sie töten?
Die Experten nehmen das Leben
des Mörders unter die Lupe.
Sie treffen sich mit ihm, befragen
seine Angehörigen und Bekannten,
nehmen Einsicht in seine Strafakten.
Ihre Diagnose:
Fabrice A. hat eine ausgeprägte
Neigung zu Sadomasochismus
und weist
starke psychopathische Züge auf.
Fabrice A. hat eine
dissoziale Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Was man als dissoziale
Persönlichkeit bezeichnet,
sind Menschen,
die wiederholt im Gefängnis landen
oder mit dem Gesetz
in Konflikt geraten.
Das sind Personen, die andere
körperlich oder verbal angreifen,
die grosse Schwierigkeiten haben,
sich der Gesellschaft anzupassen.
Wenn sie das tun, dann nur,
um einen Gewinn zu erzielen -
oft auf Kosten anderer.
Damit die Diagnose einer
dissozialen Persönlichkeit zutrifft,
muss man bereits
als Kind oder Jugendlicher
eine Verhaltensstörung aufweisen.
D.h., man muss bereits in der Schule
oder sehr jung
mit dem Gesetz oder den Regeln
in Konflikt geraten.
Das ist wichtig,
weil wir das als eine Art Fehler
im System eines Menschen sehen,
der sich dann weiterentwickelt.
Wurde Fabrice A.
mit diesem Fehler im System geboren?
Wahrscheinlich ja,
sagen die Experten.
Jedenfalls leide er nicht
an einer psychischen Krankheit
im klassischen Sinne.
Seine Entwicklung
in einer dysfunktionalen Familie
erschwert die Dinge:
Seine Schulzeit verläuft holprig,
er wird zum Kleinkriminellen.
Immer neue Gelegenheitsjobs.
Er ist instabil
und macht anderen Angst.
Er verführt, geht aber nie
eine Beziehung auf Augenhöhe ein.
Ein Element
löst bei den Psychiatern Alarm aus:
Der Moment,
in dem Fabrice A. Adeline tötet,
löst bei ihm eine Art Orgasmus aus,
eine Allmachtsorgie.
Und dieses lustvolle Gefühl,
so die Experten,
kann Fabrice A. nur erreichen,
wenn er seine schrecklichen Taten
aufs Neue ausführt.
Die Gefahr eines Rückfalls
ist somit gegeben.
Es stellt sich die Frage, ob dieses
Verhalten korrigiert werden kann.
Die Experten sind sich einig:
Es gibt also keine Therapie, die bei
dem Mörder von Adeline wirksam wäre.
Das erklärt das schwere Urteil,
das Fabrice A. erhalten hat.
Zunächst
die lebenslange Freiheitsstrafe.
Nach 15 Jahren wird
eine bedingte Freilassung geprüft.
Diese wird jedoch nur selten gewährt.
Solange Adelines Mörder im Vollzug
der lebenslangen Freiheitsstrafe ist,
ruht sozusagen die Verwahrung.
Beide Sanktionen sind unbegrenzt.
Der verurteilte Mörder kommt
mit sehr grosser Wahrscheinlichkeit
nie mehr auf freien Fuss.
Neben
der lebenslangen Freiheitsstrafe
wurde Fabrice A. zu der in Artikel
64, Absatz 1 des Strafgesetzbuchs
vorgesehenen
sichernden Massnahme verurteilt:
der ordentlichen Verwahrung.
Diese muss
grundlegende Bedingungen erfüllen:
Der Täter muss ein schweres Gewalt-
oder Sexualverbrechen begangen haben.
Und:
Das Rückfallrisiko muss hoch sein.
V.a. aber: Bei einer Verwahrung
geht das Gericht davon aus,
dass der Täter
nicht therapierbar ist.
Die Massnahme der Verwahrung
wird angetreten,
nachdem der Gefangene
seine Strafe verbüsst hat.
Ihre Dauer ist unbegrenzt.
Jedes Jahr wird geprüft, ob der
Verurteilte entlassen werden kann.
Dies ist jedoch sehr selten der Fall.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit
ist somit hoch,
dass Fabrice A. das Gefängnis
nie mehr verlassen wird.
Warum also
hat Adelines Familie Angst,
dass Fabrice A.
erneut zuschlagen könnte?
Diese Angst ist sehr stark.
Sie wird jedes Jahr grösser,
weil ich weiss,
dass ihn bisher niemand
im Griff hatte.
Das ist
ein aussergewöhnlicher Manipulator.
Der Beweis dafür ist, dass er wieder
einen Skandal ausgelöst hat.
Dieser Mann macht mir Angst!
Am 16. Mai lässt eine Genfer Zeitung
die Bombe platzen.
Fabrice A. hat aus dem Gefängnis
heraus erneut eine Frau belästigt.
Eine Frau
aus dem Hochsicherheitsgefängnis
im Kanton Zug heraus belästigen -
wie ist das möglich?
Im Frühjahr gibt Fabrice A.
telefonisch
eine Lebensmittelbestellung auf.
In dem gelieferten Paket
ist ein Werbeprospekt enthalten.
Darin
ist eine Verkäuferin abgebildet.
Fabrice A. schafft es,
sich die Kontaktdaten der jungen Frau
zu beschaffen.
Er schreibt ihr, ruft sie an.
Er wird immer aufdringlicher.
Als klar wird, wer der Stalker ist,
informiert das Ladenpersonal
die Polizei.
Im Zuger Gefängnis erhält Fabrice A.
lediglich einen Verweis.
Er habe nicht
gegen die Regeln verstossen.
Unter bestimmten Bedingungen
habe auch ein Verwahrter
nach Artikel 64 das Recht
auf Telefon, Post und Internet.
Dennoch: für die Angehörigen
von Adeline ein weiterer Dolchstoss.
Ei, ei, ei.
Dieser Kerl
ist überhaupt nicht geheilt,
er hat sich null verändert.
Das ist der Beweis dafür,
dass man mit so jemandem
nichts mehr anfangen kann.
Man denkt, zehn Jahre
können jemanden weichklopfen,
aber nichts da!
20 Jahre, 30 Jahre ...
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass den
nur das Alter ruhigstellen kann.
Wenn so was wieder passiert,
wäre es,
als ob man Adeline
nochmals töten würde.
Das löst in mir eine Menge aus.
Das ist nicht rational,
aber so fühle ich.
Tief in seinem Inneren
ist Juan nicht wirklich erstaunt
über das, was passiert ist.
In seinem früheren Leben war er eben-
falls Sozialtherapeut im Gefängnis.
Und in Kontakt
mit einem gewissen Fabrice A.
Ich kannte ihn, ein Jahr lang,
genau wie Adeline.
Er war unser Klient, unser Patient.
Man muss ihm weder böse sein
noch ihm verzeihen.
Er ist so, wie er ist.
Man muss ihn nur einsperren.
Es gibt Gefangene,
die darf man nie mehr freilassen.
Es gibt sie tatsächlich, die
Gefangenen, die nie mehr freikommen.
Für diese Schwerverbrecher
mit gestörter Persönlichkeit
ist der Artikel 64, Absatz 1
ein One-Way-Ticket
zur endgültigen Wegsperrung.
Die Gesellschaft soll vor ihnen
geschützt werden - für immer.
Eine Männer-WG beim Znacht.
Heute gibt es Dürüm.
Für das Wochenendmenü
sind Vorschläge willkommen:
Ich denke, Rahmschnitzel wäre gut.
Mit Nudeln, nehme ich an?
- Ja.
Wähe ist noch gefallen.
- Ja, gern.
Wir haben noch Rhabarber im Garten,
den man brauchen sollte.
Es ist eine geschlossene Gesellschaft
der besonderen Art:
eine WG für Verwahrte,
die einzige in der Schweiz.
Die Justizvollzugsanstalt Solothurn.
Im ehemaligen Direktorenhaus begann
vor drei Jahren das Pilotprojekt.
Sechs Verwahrte leben hier gemeinsam,
es sind schweizweit bekannte Fälle.
Ihre Taten: brutal, skrupellos.
Alle waren zuvor
in anderen Anstalten -
jahrzehntelang.
Es ist anders als im anderen
Gefängnis, wo ich vorher war.
Da gab es einen Speisesaal und
man musste in der Kolonne anstehen
und die Zeit war beschränkt.
Hier ist es vom ganzen Aufbau her
schon einfacher und viel ruhiger.
Am Freitag kommt das Unwetter,
pass auf.- Am Freitag?
Ja, am Freitag beginnt es
zu gewittern und stürmen.
Also Gewitter gibt es sicher.
Sturm weiss ich noch nicht.
Verwahrt wird, wer eine schwere
Gewalt- oder Sexualstraftat begeht
und dazu als rückfallgefährdet
und nicht therapierbar gilt.
Ist die Haftstrafe verbüsst,
bleibt der Täter hinter Gittern -
zum Schutz der Gesellschaft.
Was tun mit Menschen,
die vielleicht ihr Leben lang
im Gefängnis bleiben werden?
Besuch bei Marcel,
der eigentlich anders heisst.
Ich bin schon bald
ein Vierteljahrhundert im Gefängnis.
Wofür wurden Sie verurteilt?
- Mord.
Jeden Tag spielt Marcel
sein Lieblingsspiel: Solitär.
Er spielt immer dasselbe Level -
Internetzgang hat er nicht.
Das ist mein Bett
und das ist ein rückenschonendes,
nackenschonendes Kopfkissen,
das mir hier meinen Nacken stützt.
Dann konnte ich mir
eine TEMPUR-Matratze kaufen.
Sie ist breiter, sie federt ab
und passt sich meinem Rücken an.
Anschaffen darf er,
was er selbst bezahlen kann.
Solange der Weg noch frei ist
zum Bett, falls irgendetwas wäre ...
Es kann ja sein,
dass ich einen Herzinfarkt bekomme
oder weiss nicht, was alles.
Auch seine Arbeit hinter Gittern
darf Marcel mitbestimmen.
Tag für Tag
geht er auf Aschenbecherrunde.
Ich mache das gerne.
Du kommst unter andere Leute
und hast viel Bewegung.
Ein Schwätzchen hier, eines dort
und dann ist das gut.
Es gibt sicher Zuschauer, die sagen:
"Hey, das geht doch nicht,
dass Verwahrte mehr Freiheiten haben
und sich wohlfühlen."
Ja, das ist das grosse Thema,
nicht wahr.
Ich weiss gar nicht,
was ich dazu sagen soll,
weil ich mich so wohlfühle.
Ich bin der Überzeugung:
Wenn wir
unsere Strafe abgesessen haben,
sollte ein bisschen Erleichterung
schon sein.
Doch welche Hafterleichterungen
sollen Verwahrte haben?
Auf diese Frage
sucht u.a. der Direktor
der JVA Solothurn eine Antwort.
Nach der Verbüssung der Strafe
kommt etwas anderes: die Verwahrung.
Verwahrung heisst eigentlich nur,
dass diese Personen nicht
in Freiheit entlassen werden können.
Es ist nichts als fair,
wenn man sagt:
Wir schauen wenigstens intern -
nach wie vor
in einem sicheren Rahmen -,
dass wir
ein ganzes anderes Setting aufbauen.
Ein Setting
mit besonderen Privilegien:
Die Männer waschen selbst,
sie telefonieren, wann sie wollen,
sie kochen mit Messern und sie surfen
unter Aufsicht im Internet.
Auch einen Garten hat die WG.
Ein idyllisches Leben im Gefängnis.
Das Zusammenleben gestaltet sich gut.
Die Bewohner schätzen die WG sehr.
Eine WG, in der
sechs Schwerverbrecher zusammenleben.
Das beweist ja auch,
dass das nicht nur Unmenschen sind.
Dürfen wir reinkommen?
- Natürlich.
Das ist Ihr Zimmer.
- Ja.
Das ist mein kleines Zimmer,
das ich habe.
Hier sieht man die Aussicht
gleich auf den Weg,
wo ich immer wieder
Spaziergänger und Velofahrer sehe.
Als ich hierherkam, sagte ich nur:
"Wow, was ist das?"
Für mich
sind das einfach zwei Welten.
Ich war in verschiedenen Anstalten
und man merkt dort,
dass man immer eingeschränkt ist
und dass die Hausordnungen
einfach zu restriktiv sind.
Seit mehr als 30 Jahren
lebt Marcel hinter Gittern.
Ich mag Musik,
ich mag Radio, Nachrichten.
Ich muss einfach informiert sein.
Ich habe zwar keinen Fernseher,
aber das heisst nicht,
dass ich nicht informiert bin.
Und der Fernseher ...
Wir haben im Wohnbereich einen ge-
meinsamen Fernseher, den ich nutze.
Er weiss,
wie umstritten seine Freiheiten sind.
Haben Sie nicht das Gefühl,
die Gesellschaft will das?
Leute, die z.B. einen Mord begangen
haben, sollen es nicht schön haben.
Das kann ich bis zu einem gewissen
Grad nachvollziehen, ganz klar.
Ich habe einen Mord begangen,
jemand anderem das Leben genommen.
Ich habe eine Strafe bekommen,
16 Jahre ambulante Therapie,
die ich
erstinstanzlich akzeptiert habe.
Ich habe die 16 Jahre hinter mir -
ohne Vollzugslockerungen, pur.
Vor zwei Jahren erkämpfte sich Marcel
mit einer Beschwerde
seinen Platz in der WG.
Das Bundesgericht entschied zudem,
der Kanton müsse prüfen,
ob seine Verwahrung
in anderen Gefängnissen vorher
menschenrechtskonform war.
Ein wegweisender Entscheid
für die Schweiz.
* Mehrfaches, schnelles Piepen *
Guten Morgen, in die Montage, bitte.
Danke schön.
Marcel verbringt Teile des Tages
zusammen mit anderen Verwahrten,
die nicht in der WG wohnen.
Nach dem Umziehen
geht's an die Arbeit.
Finden Sie, alle Verwahrten sollten
in einer Abteilung sein wie Sie?
Ja, allein schon
wegen der Gleichbehandlung.
Denn es kann nicht sein,
dass die einen das haben
und die anderen nicht.
Noch lange nicht jeder
verwahrte Insasse ist in der Lage,
sich in einer solchen WG
zu bewähren.
Es wird immer Verwahrte geben,
die im Strafvollzug
in einem solchen Setting
aus Sicherheitsüberlegungen
bleiben müssen,
weil sie sich im sozialen Gefüge
nicht bewegen können,
weil sie immer wieder
aggressiv sind, provokativ sind -
auch gegenüber den anderen Insassen.
Man wird also nie
ein Konzept finden,
das für alle Verwahrten passt.
Ein Platz in der WG
kostet fast 600 Fr. pro Tag.
Das ist doppelt so viel
wie im normalen Strafvollzug.
Warum?
Das hat etwas mit der Grösse
der Wohngruppe zu tun.
Das sind sechs Plätze.
Wenn man natürlich eine Vollkosten-
rechnung macht über das Ganze,
d.h. die ganze
Sicherheitsinfrastruktur,
das ganze Sicherheitspersonal,
der Betreuungsschlüssel ...
Wenn man all das anschaut,
wird es einfach teurer.
Du hackst immer auf einer Stelle.
- Ich weiss.
Du weisst, ich schäme mich
jetzt gerade gar nicht.
Musst du auch nicht.
Ich trage die falschen Hosen,
aber das macht nichts.
Nein, die kann man waschen.
- Ja.
Ein Inhaftierter, auch
ein Verwahrter, bleibt ein Mensch.
Und der Rechtsstaat
muss ihn als Menschen behandeln.
Benjamin Brägger ist einer
der führenden Schweizer Experten
für den Strafvollzug.
Der Rechtsstaat ist der Auffassung,
dass du gefährlich bist.
Du bist im Gefängnis verwahrt
und wirst dort bleiben.
Aber trotzdem bist du ein Mensch,
der Rechte hat,
und eines davon
sind Lebensbedingungen,
die an eine so lange Haftzeit
anzupassen sind.
Nur wenige Verwahrte
kommen je wieder auf freien Fuss,
auch in der JVA Solothurn.
Dennoch geben einige Insassen
ihre Hoffnung nicht auf.
Ja, diese Hoffnung
habe ich nach wie vor.
Und auch den Glauben daran, weil es
für mich einfach existenziell ist.
Existenziell in dem Sinn,
dass auch ...
... meine Familie,
v.a. meine Mutter, daran glaubt
und ich einfach
am Ball bleiben muss.
Evtl. über Vollzugslockerungen
und dann die bedingte Entlassung,
sodass ich rauskomme.
Zurück zum Verwahrten
auf Aschenbechertour.
Seine Vollzugsbehörde prüfte, ihn
in eine offene Anstalt zu verlegen.
Doch sie kam zum Schluss,
dass er dort überfordert wäre.
Sie haben das Gefühl,
Sie bleiben hier drin bis ...
Ja.
Das habe ich wirklich im Sinn.
Wenn nichts Gravierendes passiert
oder nicht irgendein Wunder passiert
oder weiss nicht was,
aber ich bin zufrieden da.
Ich hoffe, ich kann noch lange
auf Zigarettenrunde.
Macht es Ihnen keine Angst zu denken,
hier zu sterben?
Nein, absolut nicht.
Theoretisch könnte auch
der Mörder von Adeline
in einigen Jahren
in eine solche WG umziehen.
In der Schweiz
gibt es unter rund 7'000 Inhaftierten
etwa 150 Verwahrte, die als
nicht therapierbar eingestuft werden.
Mörder. Vergewaltiger.
Zu ihnen gehört auch Fabrice A.
Die Familie von Adeline
macht sich grosse Sorgen.
Er ist ein grosser Manipulator,
ein intelligenter Mann.
Und er wird es schaffen,
wieder herauszukommen.
Niemand
kann mich vom Gegenteil überzeugen.
Tatsächlich
könnte Adelines Mutter recht haben.
Theoretisch könnte Fabrice A.
wieder freigelassen werden.
Tatsache ist jedoch,
dass die Freilassung eines Verwahrten
heute kaum mehr vorkommt.
Martin ist eine Ausnahme.
Aus der Verwahrung in die Freiheit.
Er weiss,
dass seine Aussagen schockieren
und seine Freilassung beunruhigt.
Ich wurde wegen Vergewaltigung
und sexueller Übergriffe verurteilt.
Mehrere Vergewaltigungen.
In erster Instanz
habe ich 18 Jahre bekommen.
Am Ende waren es dann zwölf Jahre
und ein Artikel 64.
Gefährlichkeit, Rückfälligkeit,
schlechte Prognose -
alle Warnlampen stehen zum Zeitpunkt
seiner Verurteilung auf Rot.
Martins Störungen sind tiefgreifend
und sie haben einen Namen:
Narzisstische Perversion,
Tendenz Borderline.
Im Grunde genommen ist es das.
Das ist keine Krankheit, die man
mit Medikamenten behandeln kann.
Das ist eine psychische Störung,
eine tiefgreifende
Persönlichkeitsstörung.
Voilà.
Martin hat sich nie gegen Therapien
gesträubt, im Gegenteil.
Ich habe
an allen Therapien teilgenommen.
Man muss dazu sagen, dass es mir in
der ersten Zeit nicht so gut ging.
Im Gefängnis geht es einem nie gut.
Aber ich musste
erst einmal aufwachen aus dem,
was ich getan hatte.
Man muss schon ziemlich
an sich arbeiten
und sich bewusst sein,
dass es ein langer Weg wird,
Gefängnis hin oder her.
Im Gefängnis arbeitet Martin
über die Jahre hinweg an sich selbst.
Die Ärzte beurteilen ihn regelmässig
und ändern schliesslich
ihre Einschätzung:
Martins Persönlichkeitsstörung
kann stabilisiert werden,
seine Gefährlichkeit
und das Rückfallrisiko nehmen ab.
Nach einer gerichtlichen Überprüfung
wird die Verwahrung nach Artikel 64
auf Artikel 59 umgewandelt.
Das ändert alles -
zumindest zunächst.
Der Artikel 59
des Schweizerischen Strafgesetzbuchs
betrifft die stationären
therapeutischen Massnahmen
von psychisch gestörten Straftätern.
Der Täter muss ein
schweres Verbrechen begangen haben,
das mit der psychischen Störung
im Zusammenhang steht,
und es muss
ein Rückfallrisiko bestehen.
Im Gegensatz zu Artikel 64,
der Verwahrung,
muss die verurteilte Person
jedoch therapierbar sein.
Eine Umstufung von Artikel 64 auf 59
ist selten.
Es mag
wie ein kleiner Schritt aussehen,
aber es ist ein riesiger Erfolg,
wenn man es schafft,
einen Richter dazu zu bringen,
einen Artikel 64
in einen Artikel 59 umzuwandeln.
Das ist sehr schwierig,
die Hürde ist sehr hoch.
Es ist machbar, aber sehr selten.
Nach langen Jahren der Inhaftierung
beginnt Martin,
von einem Leben ohne Gitterstäbe
zu träumen.
Er ist nur wenige Schritte
davon entfernt,
seine psychiatrischen Beurteilungen
sind ermutigend.
Dann geschieht das Unvorstellbare:
Fabrice A. tötet Adeline.
Die Politik
und die Strafvollzugsbehörden
ziehen sofort die Schrauben an.
Die begleiteten Ausgänge
der Häftlinge werden ausgesetzt,
ebenso die bedingten Freilassungen.
Martin ist zu diesem Zeitpunkt
seit fast 15 Jahren inhaftiert.
Sein neuer Lebensentwurf
gerät ins Wanken.
Sein Anwalt kritisiert:
Der tragische Fall Adeline
hat die Gerichts-
und Verwaltungslandschaft
völlig verändert.
Es gibt ein Vor dieser Tragödie
und ein Danach.
Was Martin betrifft,
hat er seine Strafe abgesessen.
Die Verwahrung wurde
zugunsten einer stationären thera-
peutischen Massnahme aufgehoben.
Und dann,
so viele Jahre nach seiner Tat,
für die er verurteilt
und bestraft wurde,
steht er immer noch
unter Massnahmen,
auch wenn diese
in den letzten Jahren
Schritt für Schritt
gelockert wurden.
Aber 27 Jahre, so viele Jahre,
das ist enorm!
Die durchschnittliche Dauer
der Massnahmen
nach einem Artikel 59 oder 64
ist in den letzten 15 Jahren
erheblich angestiegen.
Seit er den Strafvollzug beobachtet,
hat Benjamin Brägger erlebt,
wie sich die Prioritäten
verändert haben.
Heute geht es mehr um die Sicherheit
und die Vermeidung eines Rückfalls.
Man will das Risikopotenzial
bei einer Freilassung
besser einschätzen.
Es wird sehr genau abgeklärt,
ob ein Täter weiter gefährlich ist
und wieder
ein Verbrechen begehen könnte.
Die Vollzugsbehörden waren früher
vielleicht ein wenig lasch,
dafür sind sie heute
ziemlich streng,
vielleicht sogar
ein bisschen zu streng.
Heute werden mehr therapeutische
Massnahmen im Sinne von Artikel 59
ausgesprochen als früher.
Es ist, als würde die Psychiatrie
der Justiz zu Hilfe eilen:
Um einen Menschen,
der das Gesetz missachtet,
zu neutralisieren,
erklärt man ihn für verrückt.
Um uns Sicherheit zu geben,
ist es besser, zu denken,
dass das Mad vorherrscht,
dass Wahnsinn
hinter einer Tat steckt.
Aber oft ist das nicht der Fall.
Man fragt sich:
Gibt es Bosheit auch ohne Wahnsinn?
Deshalb
haben die therapeutischen Massnahmen
in den letzten drei Jahrzehnten
so zugenommen.
1984 befanden sich 13 Personen
mit psychischen Störungen
nach Artikel 59
im Massnahmenvollzug.
Heute sind es laut den Zahlen des
Bundesamts für Statistik über 700.
Wenn das so weitergeht,
werden wir in ein paar Jahren
mehr als 2'000 Personen
im Massnahmenvollzug haben.
Das kann nicht die Lösung sein.
Wir sollten mit den heutigen
Instrumenten in der Lage sein,
zu sehen,
ob jemand wirklich gefährlich ist
und keine Fortschritte macht,
oder ob man ihn oder sie zurück
in die Freiheit begleiten kann.
Wir brauchen
eine neue Kultur des Vertrauens.
Kein naives Vertrauen, sondern
ein wohlüberlegtes Vertrauen.
Eine Sanktion, die kein Ende nimmt.
Artikel 59 hat einen Spitznamen:
die kleine Verwahrung.
Gegen sie wehrt sich
die Genfer Anwältin Yaël Hayat.
Glauben Sie denn,
dass die Kriminellen von gestern
komplett anders sind
als die Kriminellen von heute?
Es ist unser Blick,
der sich verändert hat.
Verbrechen hat es immer gegeben,
aber unser Blick auf die Menschen
hat sich mit der Zeit verändert.
Ich verstehe natürlich,
dass es Fälle gibt,
die um uns herum
Angst und Terror verbreitet haben.
Die Massnahmen, die daraufhin
im Strafvollzug ergriffen wurden,
sind eine Antwort darauf
und ganz offensichtlich
v.a. von Angst gesteuert.
Man muss sich also
eine wichtige Frage stellen:
Ist es richtig, dass die Behörden
als Konsequenz gewisser Fälle
Urteile fällen,
die mehr von Emotionen
als von der Vernunft
geleitet werden?
Für Martin besteht kein Zweifel:
Er musste für diese Politik bezahlen.
Für mich ist das eine direkte
Konsequenz aus dem Fall Adeline.
Eine Art Übereifer,
um die Bevölkerung zu beruhigen.
Man sagt den Leuten sozusagen:
"Schaut,
die lassen wir nicht mehr raus."
Seit Ende Dezember ist Martin
von seinen Massnahmen befreit
und auf freiem Fuss.
Fühlt er sich
vor einem Rückfall sicher?
Der Martin, der immerhin
Persönlichkeitsstörungen hatte,
wird sicherlich sein ganzes Leben
lang damit zu tun haben.
Er wird damit leben müssen,
das wird nicht völlig verschwinden.
Aber er hat über die Jahre gelernt,
zumindest herauszufinden
und in Worte zu fassen,
warum er so ist,
warum er
diese Persönlichkeitsstörungen hat.
Deshalb würde ich sagen,
er ist ziemlich geläutert.
Der alte Martin ist sehr geschwächt.
Ich glaube, so kann man das sagen.
Martin hatte viele Jahre Zeit
zum Nachdenken.
Man muss schon sagen: Eine Therapie
ist etwas Egoistisches.
Etwas, das man v.a. für sich selbst
und erst danach für andere macht.
Aber man denkt dabei immer
an die Opfer.
In meinem Leben und im Leben der
Opfer ist etwas Schlimmes passiert,
das nicht wiedergutgemacht
werden kann, egal, was man sagt.
Nur weil ich eine Therapie mache,
heisst das nicht,
dass sich die Opfer besser fühlen.
Sein Anwalt begleitet Martin
schon seit Prozessbeginn.
Er ist zuversichtlich.
Ich bin überzeugt, dass Martin
nicht rückfällig werden wird.
Seine psychotherapeutische Arbeit
und seine Schritte zur Wieder-
eingliederung in die Gesellschaft
waren beispielhaft.
Er hat
einen aussergewöhnlichen Willen
und ich bin davon überzeugt:
Er schafft das.
Überzeugung allein
wird nicht reichen.
Was ist, wenn Martin, wie andere
vor ihm, erneut eine Straftat begeht,
erneut vergewaltigt?
Wer wäre verantwortlich?
Der Richter, der über die Entlassung
entschieden hat?
Oder die Psychiater
mit positiven Gutachten?
Irgendwann muss jemand
seine Unterschrift setzen,
das kann man drehen und wenden,
wie man will.
Es gibt einen Punkt,
an dem es getan werden muss.
Das ist zwar immer Teamarbeit,
aber einer muss am Ende
die Verantwortung übernehmen.
Das ist eine schwer zu übernehmende
Verantwortung.
Die Angst vor den Konsequenzen.
Und die Angst vor den Medien, wenn
die Dinge dann schiefgehen sollten.
Dramen über Rückfälligkeit
von Straftätern findet man schnell,
aber wer interessiert sich für
erfolgreiche Wiedereingliederungen?
Der Genfer Psychiater weiss,
dass es sie gibt.
Er ist der medizinische Leiter
der Strafvollzugsanstalt Curabilis.
Die Anstalt wurde kurz nach dem
tragischen Tod von Adeline eingeweiht
und ist die einzige gesicherte
forensisch-psychiatrische
Massnahmenstation in der Westschweiz.
In den rund 90 Plätzen
werden speziell Straftäter mit
psychischen Störungen untergebracht.
Sie sind im Gefängnis - und in
intensiver therapeutischer Betreuung.
Jedes Jahr verlassen 30-40 von ihnen
Curabilis in die Freiheit.
Sie sind stabilisiert und können,
so die Gutachten,
in der Gesellschaft
erneut funktionieren.
Micha ist einer von ihnen.
Er hat seine Strafe verbüsst
und ist wieder auf freiem Fuss.
Curabilis hat mein Leben gerettet.
Ich bin zufrieden, ich bin glücklich
und fühle mich schon viel freier.
Ich freue mich auf das, was kommt,
meine neuen Lebensprojekte.
Micha hat die letzten zwei Jahre in
der Haftanstalt Curabilis verbracht.
Vorher lebte er in einer Beziehung,
ging seiner Arbeit nach,
aber in seinem Kopf herrschte Chaos.
Und immer wieder entstand
aus dem Chaos das Verbrechen:
Ich hatte Wahnvorstellungen
und fühlte mich verfolgt.
Kommunikation
war für mich manchmal unmöglich.
Dazu kamen psychoaffektive
Störungen, Stimmungsschwankungen
in Verbindung
mit psychotischen Zuständen.
Eines Tages
war ich in einem solchen Zustand
und habe meine Freundin angegriffen.
Ich hörte Stimmen, die mir befahlen,
meine Freundin zu töten.
Ich habe zwar versucht,
mich dagegen zu wehren,
aber am Ende
bin ich zur Tat geschritten.
Ich habe ihr mit einem Hammer
auf den Kopf geschlagen
und dann versucht, sie zu erwürgen.
Sie hat mich angefleht, aufzuhören,
da habe ich eingehalten
und einen Krankenwagen für sie
und die Polizei für mich gerufen.
Zum Zeitpunkt der Tat
ist Micha 31 Jahre alt.
Für den versuchten Mord wird er
zu einer mehrjährigen Freiheitsstrafe
und einer Massnahme gemäss Artikel 59
verurteilt -
er gilt als gut therapierbar.
Nach einigen Monaten
in einem Genfer Gefängnis
kommt er in eine Zelle von Curabilis.
Dort beginnt
seine Arbeit an sich selbst.
Einer der Hauptfaktoren
war das gegenseitige Vertrauen
zwischen mir und meinen Betreuern.
Das hat es ermöglicht, auch
sehr schwierige Themen anzugehen.
Wir haben viel Wissen
über meine Krankheit ausgetauscht
und daran gearbeitet,
meine auseinandergebrochene
Persönlichkeit zu flicken.
Wir haben auch an
meiner Suchtproblematik gearbeitet.
Wir haben verstanden,
dass ich Alkohol oft gegen Angst
und Einsamkeit konsumiert habe
und Cannabis gegen meine Phobien.
Wir haben auch viel über meine Fa-
milie und meine Freunde gesprochen.
So konnte ich nach und nach die Be-
ziehungen zu ihnen wieder aufbauen.
Micha hat sich
mit dem Leiden seines Opfers,
seiner ehemaligen Lebensgefährtin,
auseinandergesetzt.
Sie hatte
traumatische Erlebnisse mit mir.
Der Höhepunkt
war natürlich meine Tat.
Ich fühle mich schuldig,
ich bereue alles,
was ich ihr angetan habe,
insbesondere natürlich, dass ich
versucht habe, sie zu töten.
Das hinterlässt Spuren
für das ganze Leben.
Es motiviert mich,
auf mich selbst aufzupassen,
damit sich so etwas
nicht wiederholt.
Das, was passiert ist,
ist eine Lektion für mich.
Ich weiss heute,
in welchen Situationen
es gefährlich werden könnte.
Seit dem Interview
hat Micha die Schweiz
mit dem Einverständnis seiner Ärzte
und der Gefängnisbehörden verlassen.
Er lebt im Ausland, hat eine Arbeit
und eine Wohnung gefunden.
Für seine Krankheit
nimmt er Medikamente.
Fühlt er sich geheilt?
Ich bevorzuge das Wort stabil.
Man könnte sagen,
dass ich stabil bin,
wenn ich meine Medikamente nehme
und einen gesunden Lebensstil
beibehalte.
Ich betrachte es so, wie wenn ich
eine chronische Krankheit hätte,
wie Diabetes,
wo eine langfristige medikamentöse
Behandlung notwendig ist.
Artikel 59, Artikel 64, Absatz 1,
die ordentliche Verwahrung -
keiner der beiden bietet in den Augen
von Adelines Angehörigen
genügend Schutz
vor dem Mörder ihrer Tochter.
Ihre Hoffnung zum Zeitpunkt
des Prozesses gegen Fabrice A.
lag auf Artikel 64, Absatz 1bis,
der lebenslänglichen Verwahrung.
Sie ist die strengste Massnahme
des Schweizerischen Strafgesetzbuchs.
Urlaub und vorzeitige Haftentlassung
sind hier ausgeschlossen.
Eingeführt wurde
die lebenslängliche Verwahrung 2004
im Rahmen einer Volksinitiative.
Diese Massnahme
wird von vielen Juristen
als menschenrechtswidrig angesehen.
Bisher wurde sie
nur ein einziges Mal angewendet.
Das ist eine so extreme Massnahme,
dass sie
jedes Recht auf Hoffnung nimmt.
D.h., was immer auch der Häftling
unternimmt, um an sich zu arbeiten,
es gibt keine Aussicht
auf Vergebung.
Eine lebenslängliche Verwahrung
bedeutet,
dass man jemanden
quasi in die Todeszelle steckt,
weil er nichts mehr
vom Leben zu erwarten hat.
Ihm das Recht auf Hoffnung
zu nehmen,
bedeutet in gewisser Weise,
ihm den Tod einzuhauchen.
Soll man
auf die Barbarei eines Verbrechens
mit der Barbarei einer Bestrafung
antworten?
Das ist die Frage.
Unsere Tochter
wurde zu lebenslänglich verurteilt.
Adeline hätte noch 50 Jahre
Mutter sein können.
Unserer Tochter wurden also
50 Jahre mit ihr genommen.
Das ist auch ein Lebenslänglich.
Das Leiden von mir,
von Adelines Eltern und Geschwistern
ist lebenslänglich.
Bei ihm weiss man das nicht.
Adeline
wurde vor zehn Jahren ermordet.
Zehn Jahre, in denen ihre Angehörigen
Tag für Tag den Verlust spüren.
Und: eine grosse Angst.
* Unheilvolle Musik *
Er hat
keine lebenslängliche Verwahrung.
D.h., dass er ab 15 Jahren Haft
alle zwei Jahre neu beurteilt wird.
Als Manipulator wird er Einfluss
auf seine Umgebung ausüben,
besonders, wenn vergessen geht,
was er getan hat.
Ich kann nicht in Frieden sterben,
im Bewusstsein,
dass er eines Tages erneut unserer
Familie oder anderen Menschen
Schaden zufügen kann.
Das macht mir so viel Angst, dass
ich nicht in Frieden sterben kann.
* Melancholische Klavierakkorde *
SWISS TXT / Accessibility Services
Madeleine Gassner - 2024